that is okay gentlemen pitcher by Sai
Baba that you're by psychobabble
you know what five hundred think I've
ever was or is the webcam I missed it
beautiful safe and it's had to say like
I say so I got stuck in a tractor wheel
and it's all jacked up anyway so playing
theorem today and let's see if their
campaign I guess let's just start it you
know yeah right don't hurt me plenty
you know the USA cracks answer a7 what
seventeen that doesn't sound like a
Bible verse and well maybe I misread the
bottle house they ou rage brutto
without mercy but you you will be worse
ribbon tear I'll change
dumb
oh my god my see it they're so dry come
on do your eyes play like that you know
I guess nobody knows with that done my
own execution
obviously they're praising right that's
how I have their hair dye want me to
continue
but what yeah it might look older
yes I don't like that I do like that
a my master tree this is the next hallo
demonic invasion in progress okay
initiating scan errors oh my god there's
so many errors mostly that nothing was
found try sir out okay that's headline
back online there no good thing never
where I came to to look at it so I can
tell them what it looks like
welcome I'm dr. Samuel Hagan on the head
of this facility I think we can work
together and resolve this problem in a
way their life it's possible second and
understand that's disgusting
I hate Turkey
[Music]
yes panel glory kills they stagger go up
impressive glory kill Kenny they go
ahead sister honestly it's just a little
joke sinner and I don't need to do that
okay can I get a good gun what is it but
you know okay
Shaka can I let that stop me now this is
a partner for everybody this [ __ ] it
[Music]
very quick
okay um suggest my headset okay what am
I supposed to pay down all that around
[Music]
we're just we're bizarre
these guys they got a go you know mess
with the past I like their app don't
camera I got these lock down the whole
thing okay come on tell me I got my
football like this like a worse time
yeah Bobby
drop fantastic
[Applause]
laughs it is not throw up all right
where is it where is it ouch okay store
the corn after you let me finally safely
exit not hello come on
go faster where's kind of demons in here
we change weapons Alex yeah yeah he
loved them I'm willing to take full
responsibility for the hall of events of
the last 24 hours but you must
understand our interest in there
everything has clearly gotten out of
hand
but it was the risk why were you yes
but that's the Adhan and
and
oh hi on the down automat
find the resources
okay if you say so
got it so I don't know if it's I wanted
to take a minute whether that's the date
iconic brand
what has gone on here Anna you know you
think you know someone here that she'll
go beneath
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah thanks just like on that's a
sorrowful bloody and that drunk lexicon
hot think I'm supposed to go
where to go
okay where am I supposed to go run an
old bellman find the entrance I really
feel like mad at you
check my breached okay so I do the black
tell requires we should tell me that
that right yes I came in this way
okay this way
yep
not mad if I don't mind if I do
okay I got you step
at arthritis
[Music]
Carolyn just get lanthanides again so
many
I got to go this way anyway what is that
thing
Oh
yeah
perfect
[Music]
meanwhile Emma
right there gone down a little bit early
ultra valve you know
[Music]
OOP
[Music]
it's like I don't have that much I'll
have to be like
[Music]
oh my god I was about to get up there
like I ran it
okay yeah you know forget
like I look like a turtle
gonna take a realtor well so that's a
Mayan rain you know just doing what I
feel is important so my god
[Applause]
[Music]
but I love how
whether I get more he's gonna keep
climbing sighs laughs more like 40
Oh
[Music]
okay anyone actually know where so they
go
[Applause]
okay I think the area is still locked
down right here lockdown
[Applause]
who says faster where's versatile okay
I like
what the heck is that near that
Radha that might have been sugar I've
got one of its time-base actually
[Applause]
welcome to unity now 201 1 X 2 2 3 days
I guess
all right yeah okay oh that's Reverend
pear y'all pay so I'll be good yeah